Hello everyone, welcome to the new features of Android.
Or I am the only one to call it
Android Keynote people
I am Chet Haase from the Android UI Toolkit team
And I am Romanie Guy from the graphics team.
I am Dan Sandler from the system UI team.
We don't have a lot of time to get started.
Are you ready for the new features of Android?
This is the place we talked about last time, API 25
We are going to mention Git-sha
Put it in git-diff and we can start
You will want to write it down
it is good
Next
Yes, very good
I really like those
Oh, man, remember that we almost made it an enumeration?
so funny
Do you understand?
Do you think this is the purpose of everyone coming here?
I don't know why we didn't think about it before.
We have been talking about this all the time -- we are always telling you
New things in these years
You can see
I forgot to take a blazer
Actually, I have a very beautiful red blazer.
But someone borrowed it for this keynote speech.
You have you --
It looks like you are
But this year
A little different, right?
Developer previewed in advance
You saw a lot of these APIs
You have a Google keynote
Where did we show off a lot of exciting things?
We arranged a developer keynote
You can learn more about developers from it.
So what are we doing here?
What is the significance of the new Android features?
Existential crisis
Have you tested this clicker?
I tested
Ok
Imagine this speech
Like a tasting or a whiskey tasting or one of them
You can press all the buttons of the soda machine
This is your carefully selected handcrafted version in the new Android or ignored
Anything you must do
To be part of Android O
To be honest, what we want to talk about on the podium
So, this is really a new feature of Android.
Specifically
You may have missed a developer preview.
Or I/O keynote or other keynotes. That's why you should care.
I want to make sure that the last thing we know today
This is it
Everyone is always excited about this O
We have to stay until the end
Oh
This will be fine
Ok, let's get started.
Roman, please talk about UI and graphics
The first thing we want to talk about
That is what you saw in the keynote speech this morning.
Chet, this clicker can't.
You have not tested
Oh
You know what --
waste time
I want to stand here behind.
I want to give you a slide
Ok
Please go to the next slide
This is what they don't want
Give me a reason for a clicker
Ok, this feature --
This is useful to me
You go back there
I don't want to see you.
You saw this in one of the keynote speeches this morning.
The first function - picture in picture
Not just TV
The phone can also be seen
Here is an example of a third-party application
Netflix runs picture-in-picture on your phone
Give me that clicker
We moved to the back
That's right
This is really easy
Implemented in your application
You only need to modify the list.
And stop playing the animation
Just need to say support for picture-in-picture, really
In O, you no longer need to resize the activity
Set to true
You have to test the configuration changes
In the code, if you want to enter the picture in picture mode
You only need to call
Enter your event and call enterPictureInPicture
Super simple, this will make your users very happy
This is a very intimate feature
That is color management
We add support for wide color gamut replacement O
This won't show on all devices
Only on devices that support this feature
Will be enabled in your app
We are also adding support for 16-bit PNG files.
Then the color can be brighter and more saturated
We support ICC files, so the color profile
Configure embedded in JPEGs PNGs, bitmaps in WebPs
Ensure accurate
Reproduce colors on multiple screens
We also have some brand new APIs.
We are late this week
Talk about this in different speeches
Because a picture is worth a thousand words
This is color management and how it works.
I hope that I have clearly expressed
But color management is about
Something that might have been encountered in your own application
Looks different colors on different devices
At Android O we have a solution
If you want to know more
I will have a speech
On Friday at 11:30 am in Hall 2
The theme of the speech is "Understanding Colors"
Next, we also add support for multiple monitors.
If your application already has --
This clicker is scary
If your app already supports multiple windows
Multi-window mode
Then in O it already supports multiple windows when the phone is connected
Or a network device connected to multiple displays
And you have a compatible app
Users can choose to send apps to you on different monitors
When this happens
You will get the adjustment configuration changes
You can also control what your activities show.
You can use the event option
You should seriously test the application
If you want to support this feature
To help you test, we have two new development tools.
You can run adb shell dumpsys display
This will list all the displays currently available on the device.
If you call the adb shell to start your activity intent
You can specify which display you want to start the event.
This is a very simple way for you to test
Those APIs have more features
I suggest you go to office hours.
Friday and Thursday
This is Windows and active office hours
Next, the media
We have a lot of courses about media packaging.
Media player media recorder, extractor
Codec
We've added a new getMetrics API course
To each of the above classes
This helps inquiring
Information about the media you are working on
So you can query the resolution codec, bitrate
Duration, such data
They are super easy to use
Just call getMetrics on one of the objects
You will get PersistableBundle
You can also find documentation at developer.android.com
To find out what kind of query is available
Playback has also been greatly improved
Now you can control the buffering in the application.
You can specify a high watermark and a low watermark
Then the video won’t start playing.
Until the low watermark is reached
The system will try to keep it
Cache data between this low and high watermark
You can specify
The duration of the watermark or the amount of data
We also improved the search
When you search for a video
Now you can choose behavior
You want to search for the closest frame
To the next frame, the previous frame
Or the closest sync frame
Finally, we make DRM rebate
Easier to use with Widevine
In all apps
As for the recording, until now
The media mixer only allows one video track and/or one track to be added
Now you can add as many tracks and video tracks as possible
You can also create custom track video tracks.
MIME type must start with "application/"
Basically a sideband you can encode any type of data.
An example of a specification is
If you want to play a 360-degree video or something like that, you need to encode the JavaScript data.
WebView comes with new and useful APIs
We added this safe browsing feature
This is a feature you know and love in chrome
Helps detect malware and unsafe web pages
If you add this tag to your list this metadata tag
It will use the same backend and the same API
This API, Chrome itself is also in use
To ensure a browsing experience for users
Now WebView uses multiple programs
In particular, there is a renderer
So we also have a brand new API to handle these multiple programs.
If the renderer system crashes
You can use the Termination Handle API to detect crashes.
And decide what to do with the application
Can crash the app if you want
Then try restarting the WebView
Or just log something and display a message to the user
This is much more beautiful than before
You can also use the Renderer Importance API.
Used to better handle memory shortages
When the system has insufficient memory
It will try to reclaim memory from somewhere
You can tell the system
Whether this WebView is important or not important to the application
If WebView is critical to the application
Then be sure to check out this API
You know this is the right button, right?
Yes, I know
There are several features that have been asked for animators for a long time.
Specifically for AnimatorSets
It took a while to implement the implementation, which seemed to be tricky.
But now in Android O, in AnimatorSets
We have the ability to search
Now if you have one
Animator with a collection of Child Animators
You can search for those Child Animators
In the entire AnimatorSet
correct
We also have this feature
To convert
Hey, Chet, have you tried?
Which APIs were implemented not long ago?
possible
Ok
Who is implementing those APIs?
not me
Yes
Completely correct
New performance again in AnimatorSet
Mutual conversion
You no longer need to set one
Have an independent AnimatorSet with all the features and find an audience and the like
We have done all the tedious work for you.
Autofill is really a very tedious job.
Make all the information correct
Earlier we saw it in the keynote speech.
This is the ability
To fill out a form
There is a provider who can give you information
So when you get those text fields
We can automatically fill in that information for you.
There are several aspects that are different
Of course you can carry out your own services.
And provide that function
Or rely on the services we are providing
Or more typical you will execute a client
Standard view works properly
If you are using a TextView, if you are using EditText
We already know how to receive this information
To interact with the service
So you don't need to do anything with the standard view.
If you use a custom view
Or you have to provide more information about the standard view.
We have APIs to provide us with
Tips and APIs for what numeric types are
Let us tell us more about custom views.
And how do you want to interact with it?
If you have a custom view hierarchy
Suppose you have a SurfaceView
There are some views inside, but we only know that there is a SurfaceView
Then there is an API telling us
About the virtual level you want to interact with
We will say more in the speech on Friday morning.
So go to the one if you want to
Learn more about autofill
Now let's talk about the text.
This time there are a lot of things happening in the off text.
I think we can rewrite these
That's right
I only use that font because it makes Dan feel hurt.
This hurts him physically
it's great
I think you hurt him.
Ok, first
You can use XML to declare font information.
Use a good data binding technique
But doing it is a bit tricky
Why should we not
Actually provide that function for you?
Now we have provided
Now you can put a font document directly
Go to this new resource font directory
Yes, it is.
Put it in the catalog or you can tell us
Related font series
You can provide a few fonts
With each style of information
Then you can use it just like any other resource
Give me this resource from the code.
That's right
Downloadable font
Now we have this feature
Declare a font you want to use
If it is not already in the system then we will download and cache it on the system.
If the system already exists, we will use it from the cache.
You can do this using code or XML
And use it as a resource just like you use XML fonts
Exciting slides before that
We also have a font provider
This is an unreleased version
On Google Play Services
We have a beta this week.
For everyone to use at the meeting
I still don't know the details.
But there will be a meeting where you can learn about those details.
Or you can go to the Play Services website
to know more information
This allows you to use all Google fonts
If you only want to use standard fonts
For example the beautiful font I am using
Maybe that is already inside
Then you can ask directly from the service desk
Also has the ability to automatically adjust the TextView
Generally if you want to adjust the size of the TextView
You won't know
That will become a sensational thing, right?
text
The text is cool
Especially when it is a suitable font
Now what you get is the behavior on the left
Where we just adjusted the size of the view itself
Font has not changed
On the right, if you choose to automatically adjust the TextView behavior
Then we will adjust the font size for you
You can specify behavior
Or when it's resizing, you want to capture a specific size of step increment
There are APIs for this
XML and Java programming language code in the API
Enjoy it all.
All these text features
XML fonts, downloadable fonts and auto-adjust TextView
What new features do they support in the library tomorrow morning?
Meeting will talk about these features
You may think, why are they going to be
Do you talk about these things at the Support Library conference?
Are these not APIs for the O platform?
Yes, they are
Not also they also belong to the Support Library
You can also use these new features on earlier versions.
AccessibilityService Utilities
If you are writing AccessibilityService
This is a great thing
We have some brand new features you can use
Language detection
You can place a button and other buttons in the navigation bar.
To make it easier to visit your things.
Separated volume control achieves barrier-free volume
Then you won't put that volume
Blend with other volume on the device
There is also the ability to define custom fingerprint gestures
If you want to know more about it
There was a speech in the afternoon with the theme of barrier-free access.
You should look
Finally, there is a small change that I like very much.
I want to say that it is very tiny.
Because this is a line of API code
But the actual cls is used to fix all the code
Widely relying on the execution of the former
I don't want to damage its work
But the API is really tiny, hidden
Looks like the same thing from the outside
findViewById was previously declared with a party like this,
Public view, findViewById
Then you declare, pass to the resource ID
Get back a view
Then immediately put it into what you want
So TextView, you have to tell TextView,
On the left and right, then there are brackets
This is very troublesome
People use the subsidy library just to avoid this situation.
This looks terrible
just now
We have this
I call this new feature Castaway
I think I am the only one to do this.
Ok, skip my first slide
That's fine
I want to say a little more about the system UI.
This is what you all want to see.
If you have an app
Then you need to understand the adaptive icon
I think one of the slides at Steph earlier was mentioned a little earlier today.
In essence, we are working hard to save you time and money.
There are so many launchers outside
And each has different suggestions for the shape of the icon.
The adaptive icon is a new technology that we bring to you in O
Enable you to say
This is my backstage, this is my front desk.
Cut out the shapes you like
Even if the launcher has a circle
Or a rounded rectangle or something scary
You guys will have a fully matched local feature that is the icon
There will be a lot of information on the adaptive icons in the speech on Thursday.
And will definitely mention this topic
Ok, let's talk about shortcuts and widgets.
Because the launcher is also part of the system UI
Previously, put shortcuts and widgets on the user's screen.
There is a slightly useful broadcast shortcut
As for the widgets, you only need to ask the user, please, please.
See if we can find our widget in the launcher
At O, now you can actually ask for one of them here.
Fixed in the user's workspace
Use shortcut shortcuts
Application widget manager using widgets
Then the user has a chance to say no
I don't want to put it on the desktop or well, I want
And in fact I will continue
Put it where I want it
Or they can say, of course, find a place for it
This is the previous behavior
Now users don't have to go through a long process
You just need to send them to this dialog
This is super convenient
Look at all the new users you will be on the widget
I will say that I was suspended because of the applause.
But I am actually getting this clicker.
We will talk about this again at 4:30 pm on Thursday.
Ok, notice, you know that you are coming soon.
They are super useful
They are great for interaction
Users love them very much
But it may be a bit out of control
There are a lot of things for notification streaming now.
You are very difficult
Send the message to the user
Users are also hard to pay attention to the inflow of demand
If not controlled now
Users should always be in control
This is the principle we have been pursuing.
From the packaging of a Jelly Bean, we added a feature to block notifications
At Nougat we made a little more refined and added silence
But all this
The first request the user made to us was
Can I block some notifications from an application?
on the other hand
The first request that developers make to us is
Can the user intercept some of my notifications?
This is the same thing
Everyone has been asking the same thing
This is the source of the notification channel.
In O this is a brand new API
One channel is a notification category for the app
They all have the same behavior
Vibration, sound, flash whether or not it pops on the screen
Users can control clearly and carefully
This is an app you can set all your own channels
Define default behavior for O
Pop up a private message
Label does not pop up or its priority is lower
Then the user long presses a notification
Or use the new swipe gesture to view
They can see which channel is open
Then make changes in the row
Once you are targeting O, there is no time to be taken away in these two minutes.
I have to take this
For each notification, you must use the channel
Otherwise they will be discarded
Until you are against O, you can start slowly.
Develop the notification system into a channel
Once you are targeting O, they must be fully channelized.
Because we want a consistent experience
Users know what they will get
We are going to talk about this
There are many other great things
Including design considerations
No code placed here is flashing little things over there
Speech at 4:30 pm tomorrow
There is a lot of system UI, great stuff
We have listed some here
It is finished again
I like to use slides.
I strongly encourage you to check out the developer preview.
Or install the beta and try all the features
We are proud of it
New API for US developers
We extended the restricted mode API
I believe that you will all use it for debugging.
Current ThreadPolicy
You get a warning when using unbuffered I/O
If you use an input stream or an output stream
But without wrapping it into a buffer stream, you will see a flash.
Or something else, this is the default trigger warning.
If there is no sockets tag on VmPolicy
Also get a warning
Put Sockets tag
It’s really useful for debugging traffic with Android Studio
Finally, if you open another intent
If you send an intent to the outside of the app
Need to grant a license
Also get a warning
In fact, this is easy to use.
Looks like the previous API
Media file access
We introduced this file provider not long ago.
They are very useful just before a few releases.
Unless you have large documents
If it is a large document
You need to download the entire data.
Can pass it to the user of the file provider
Now you can create searchable file descriptors
For audio, video
Or any large file is very useful
This is very easy to use
You use the StorageManager to open the proxy file descriptor.
Give it a callback
Then we have to call this callback
Request file size
Requires the amount of data in some byte arrays
Then we have to tell you when to turn it off
Cache data
This is a brand new API
System makes you a better citizen
Each application has a certain amount of data
Can be used in cache partitions
Insufficient storage when system space is low
Will start deleting some cached data
If you keep below the preset indicator
Can prevent data from being deleted
For this, you can use StorageManager
Used to view
The number of bytes allocated to the application
You should check it from time to time.
Because the quota can be changed
It depends on how much quota is used
Or how often the user uses the app
When you want to deploy data
Can use allocateBytes
You can do it yourself
Just create a file
You can create an output stream
This is much better
Because when you double check the allocateBytes, as needed
The system will delete the cached data of another application
Free up space to store data
This means getCacheQuotaBytes
Or more than
Free space on the device
You can also use the name
setCacheBehaviorTombstone stuff
Very useful for applications
Can tell you that there has never been a cache with a cache
But the difference between the deleted files
When you set the behavior
The system deleted some files in the cache.
This will shorten the file
The file will still be there, but the size will be set to 0
This tells the cache file that it has been deleted by the system.
Finally, available space and allocatable space
Is different
There are a lot of Android security in this version.
And we only have a little time to talk about it.
I want to emphasize some privacy agreements.
This is a new feature of Android O.
If you always use Android ID
Need to know now
Each application has a different device for each user.
It is not able to track users on the same device between applications
Again, if you have been reflecting
System property to get net.hostname now it is empty
If you want to say
I really need to advertise with ID to make it available to users.
Send a situation-specific ad
This is the function of the Advertising ID API in Google Play Services.
Go check it out on Google Play.
But you can't use Android ID
You can't believe it in the same way as before.
I have a slide on WebView here.
But Roman took it away.
I have another thing to mention.
This is about safe browsing of WebView because now WebView
Put it to the Play Store every six months
You will be able to choose a safe browsing function.
It’s great before Lollipop.
We also saw some new features in the keynote speech.
We call it Google Play Protect
In fact, it involves a lot of technologies that have been in place before.
But there is really no visibility
And indeed they are worthy of visibility
Every moment, we always look after people
Any device that has Google Play Protect enabled
Any app uploaded to Play
Will be pre-screened and will be re-screened as each new version is uploaded
Whenever you install the app
Play Protect has been set up
The application will also be screened
Even if installed from another location or ADB
We are really excited
There is still a lot to talk about.
A lot of talk about Android security
They gave me the whole slide
I said why do you not give a speech?
In fact, I won’t say this anyway, they also have their own speeches.
Thursday 2:30 pm
You have to go there and find out the new features of Android security.
From beginning to end
Reinforced from Kernel
Go to WebView all content
Language and runtime
I think you already know what I am going to say.
This morning we announced official support for Kotlin.
You saw Steph on the stage and I saw her sitting there.
In the foyer
If you meet her at I/O, say thank you to her.
Steph and the entire team behind her
I have done a lot of wonderful work in the past.
It took a lot of time to bring you this
Say thank you to her.
She will pass your gratitude to the whole team.
Available today for Android 3.0
There are already many online documents
I can spend a few hours talking about Kotlin.
Why is this good for you? Why is this good for us?
In fact, should I hijack this speech?
He can
In fact, he is really great.
In fact, he is very good.
Unfortunately
We don't have that much time in this section.
I have to invite you to Friday morning at 10:30 am
Come here
There is a presentation called Kotlin, hosted by Andrey Breslav
He is the lead language designer from JetBrains.
And Hadi, who is the VP of Developer Advocate at JetBrains
Then in the afternoon in the lecture hall 4
The theme is "Life is good, everything will be OK, Kotlin is here."
By Christina Lee from Pinterest
And Jack Wharton from Square
This is very important to us
Because we brought you Kotlin
That is, your community is using Kotlin.
We heard it, I heard your voice and brought what you want.
So we want to speak from your community to the stage.
And speaking better than us
Also, if you have any questions
Can come to the developer sandbox at the Android Platform booth
Today from 3:00 pm to 4:30 pm Thursday from 2:00 pm to 4:00 pm
Friday from 12:00 noon to 2:00 pm pm
Andrey language designers will also be there
Answer all your questions
If you want to know everything about Kotlin, please go there.
Just go there and ask your questions.
Now, as Steph mentioned, we are also multiplying other languages.
Java programming language
We also have C and C++
For the Java programming language
We are adding new packages to Android O
We have java.time it finally makes it easier
Manipulating time and date
This makes sense
It makes more sense to compare older APIs
This is a matter of time.
Yes, this is a matter of time.
We also brought java.nio.file
It improves the wonderful old java.io.file API
Allow you to access the properties of the file
Let you easily manipulate the path and read the file
Let's take a look at an example.
The last is java.lang.invoke
Slightly changing version of reflection
This is roughly approximate it is really cool
It lets you handle the conversion and packaging methods in your application.
This is an example of a new archive API
You can use the path category to get the path
Then just call files.lines
It will read the contents of the entire file
You will also get a stream
In this example, I use lambdas and the stream API
To delete all empty rows and columns and all rows and columns
Both started with the pound sign and then I put everything
Collecting the last single stream
This is much easier than before.
Ok, this is some changes at runtime.
We have heard of some content this morning.
There are more this week
Concurrent now - copy collector
Basically make everything faster and better
Concurrency - replication means no pause time
Unless there is a complete GC
It can do it all
Things that need to be done in the background while you are still doing other things
Especially the best of them is
It can actually press the front desk
Previously, I believe in previous versions
It’s really good at pressing the front desk.
Can be defragmented to make those heaps smaller
Can make distribution and collection faster
It can do this when the activity is in the background
It will go idle
Then when you are idle, do it
When it is in the foreground
It is impossible to extend those heaps
And defragmentation
Now it can be collected in the foreground
Defragmentation at the front desk is getting faster
There is also a new and faster mechanism for configuration
We only need to do pointer collision allocation
This is much faster
Collect faster
And all this basically leads to less delay
Collect everything faster and collect everything faster.
It means that you only need to deal with garbage and generally use ART memory in the O version much faster.
Many different optimization loops are unfolded, inline
One of the things worth noting
When Dalvik was created, its memory type was limited, right?
It's all about saving memory with Dalvik
This also means that it can only
Do so many optimizations
It's a bit like reaching the end of life
Do things as optimized as possible
When the ART goes online, basically they are placed on the platform.
We are able to create future optimizations
Now we are starting to pick those benefits
Including each version
Including O and future versions
We are going to be able to do more and more
They still have a bunch in this version
You should know about the speech later this week.
More information on this
And the DEX area
This particularly improves the start-up time of the event.
Because we collect all the memory in the same space
It's easier and faster to access when the app is starting up
There is a speech on Friday morning.
Topics for performance, memory and improvement
Go there to see more details
In addition to the platform we also have a support library
We have other mechanisms for transferring things
This is not only available in the O version
We would like to mention some of these examples.
Have a v26 test version
Published with Developer Preview 2
This is what we have already said about text, fonts and XML
Downloadable fonts, and things that automatically adjust the TextView
All there
You can check it out.
There are also some things we call EmojiCompat.
The biggest emojis problem is
If your friends send you some emojis
And these emojis come from future standards
Instead of a running version
Then you can't see those emojis
Will only see some squares
Although I have seen some more attractive emojis, it doesn't make much sense.
If you guys can put the updated emojis
Is it not good to put it on the device?
Now we have two mechanisms
The application can be used to update emojis
One is that the application is actually bundled with the updated emojis
They can go to the Play Store to update the app.
Then their users update
Users can get more timely emojis
Another possibility is a better long-term solution
Actually using a service
We can provide downloadable fonts
Before we mentioned that they can pass the downloadable font
Automatically get updated, right?
An application can be built as
Features with downloadable fonts
To use the updated emojis as long as we provide the service
Say again, tomorrow morning
A presentation to the new features of the support library for more information
We also have more things about animation.
In addition to the AnimatorSet
The little things I mentioned just now
Now we have physics based animation materials
If we want to watch an animation form
Ability to have basic animation
This is a speed driven animation
The performance of all animations on our platform so far
Driven by the concept of this duration
By you telling it how long it will take to run
But there are a lot of animations
You really want to drive at speed
especially
Animation driven by user interaction
You drag something on the screen
If it starts off from your finger
Is it not good to drag at the same speed as when you let go?
Hey, scroll, all things
It really needs a speed-based animation system
You can do this with animators
It's really boring
It needs mathematics
Math is difficult
We put that performance hot
To this new physical animation system
This system is more natural
More interaction, more disruptive
Because it really intends to use that user interaction model
Here is a small demo
When we drag the circle at the top
The other two circles are basically
Link to the top with your defined spring
So they follow in space
Not using locksteps
Basically on the connected spring
They immediately benefit from interaction
And the physical concepts of these springs
There is a speech on Friday afternoon about this.
All about new physics-based animation materials
If you want to know more information, please go there.
Architecture component
This has been mentioned in the keynote speech
We think sometimes Android development
A little harder than needed
We take a step back and say, OK
What are the main problems that we should do?
For application developers to try to simplify?
There are still a few now we have specifically run
Or around the life cycle
Obviously it is so difficult to deal with
The fact that your activities may die at any time
When you rotate the screen or it goes to the background
Or any other thing
See exactly where you are
This may be a bit boring
And this is an ongoing problem for all application developers
Need to deal with
We took another route
Make this easier
And we
Also looked at persistence
Now you can issue the original SQL
This is all the things on your system.
We have a brand new approach which builds on this performance
Make it easier to use and more powerful
We have to talk about this week.
We want to have an introduction to the architecture components
I will advise you to go there this afternoon.
In fact, after this speech
Then tomorrow morning
We will mention life cycle issues
And how we solve the problem
A method for persistence and offline
These are some bit by bit, but in fact you can
Try on a table in an earlier version
So check it out
Hope this will make your developers a little easier
There are also some behavior changes
You will be more concerned about some of the changes compared to others.
There are also some changes to the background app behavior.
Especially location
If you run as a background app
Just get rough location information
Doing these things in order to make it harder
And make the device better, right?
If all applications have these features at any time
Or at any time they can do anything to do
Then basically this will run out of power
Everyone is doing too much work.
We try to be right
Which applications actually need service at which time?
Enable us to serve users
Bring a better experience
Your users also have a better experience.
One of them is the location
These inaccurate information when you are in the background
The other is the wake lock
We noticed that this is very common
First the application will enter the background state and then enter the cache state.
There will be a wake lock at the time
Just save that wake lock
It will save for a long time
This will really drain the battery
Now enter the cache state for a while
Wakeup lock will automatically release
Make the device not
Enter the untimely state
Will also limit the program
When executed in the background
Warning dialog also has some changes
Especially, this new type of window
Type Application Overlay
If you are targeting the O SDK
You must use this type of window if you want to warn the dialog function.
If you use the earlier version, obviously this window does not exist.
You will not use this window.
No matter which window type you are using
They are layered under this type of application overlay window
Because now we have a clearer definition
Stratification policy
We have more information at 5:00 this afternoon.
Background checks and other insights
If you want to know more details, we will see you later.
Finally, we promised to come back here, right?
correct
there's one more thing?
Ok
Let’s talk about this again.
I mean, we are playing drums, aren't we?
How about a chicken leg roll?
Can we eat a chicken leg roll?
Ok
It sounds pretty good
Unfortunately, I looked at the timer on the stage.
I want to say, O stands for
Oh
Oh, don't be like this.
We have no time
thank you all